Transportation food housing these are
some of the biggest categories in the
Consumer Price Index Market Basket one
of the measures used to track inflation
and here's how they're weighted you can
see housing or what the BLS calls
shelter makes up about a third of the
Market Basket which means it can be a
big factor in either driving or
tempering inflation I think the shelter
shelter inflation is going to remain
high for some time you know we're
looking for it to come down but it's not
exactly clear when that will happen but
it's also one of the hardest numbers to
measure and as you can see here it can
keep Rising even when inflation in other
items begins to slow down that can make
things complicated for the fed and
policy makers if they're trying to push
inflation down as they are right now
here's why housing is one of the
trickiest items in the basket to measure
and why it holds so much weight in the
overall index
when the BLS measures for shelter it's
measuring for the service that a housing
unit provides its occupants or more
simply the cost or value of your home
you think of how much money you spend
every month a big chunk of that goes to
your rent or your mortgage and that's
the case for households across the
country so if it's a big part of your
monthly spending it's going to be a big
part of the overall inflation
calculation the index includes changes
in prices for four different categories
but these two are the most important
rent and something called owner's
equivalent rent let's look at this one
first on the surface it's pretty
self-explanatory it tracks prices people
pay for rent while it's less volatile
than home prices measuring for rent
poses some challenges for the BLS
because it's sticky that means it
changes infrequently since most prices
are locked in place throughout a lease
term but that sticky price means the BLS
has to gather data for it differently
than it does for other categories data
for things like food and transportation
are gathered every month or two but it's
only gathered for rent every six sample
areas called panels report on a
staggered schedule so one might report
prices in January and July while in
other reports in February and August
that means that changes in rent might
not trickle into the bls's data for
months down the line what the BLS is
trying to do is it's trying to capture
both the people who are in the market
for a new apartment who are signing new
leases and the people who are in their
existing lease who are paying the same
price they're paying the last month so
WLS is trying to get a picture of the
overall Market sort of every renter
according to a study by the Dallas fed
changes in the rental market can proceed
changes in the shelter index by about a
year you have to wait for enough people
to sign new leases or to renew their
leases for those price increases to
actually show up but this isn't even the
trickiest part the other even bigger
slice of the index is called owner's
equivalent rent or oer this is the price
an owner would pay to rent a comparable
home
the BLS doesn't Factor house prices into
the CPI so they don't show up directly
in this that's because it considers home
ownership and investment rather than a
consumable good or service like food or
airplane tickets so instead the BLS
assigns owned homes an equivalent rent
based on the average rental prices in
the area it's an estimate so rental
prices can cause a lag and oer can be
somewhat imprecise and you can see that
that can make the shelter index look
really different from what's actually
happening in the housing market that can
make a difference in inflation numbers
because as you can see here shelter is
taking up an increasing share of the
overall CPI
here's Douglas Holtz Eakin former
director of the Congressional budget
office on the importance of bringing
shelter inflation down If the Fed wants
to hit a two percent Target and and
shelter inflation's at six percent
everything else has to be zero that's
not going to happen so the FED needs to
bring down shelter price inflation and
it will increasingly raise rates and
tighten Financial conditions until it
does this pressure means the shelter
index is lag can make things complicated
for fed officials we're looking to
affect overall inflation month to month
the last thing they want to see right
now is inflation going up I mean they've
already put in place a number of rate
increases they have more planned so
they're really looking for signs that
inflation is coming down and this is
pushing in the opposite direction even
if it's you know likely to be temporary
fed Governor Christopher Waller said in
October that while housing inflation
should slow increases in broader
interest rates should help moderate
demand and damp inflation in other
sectors in the meantime though there
isn't a specific date that the shelter
index could start to cool economists
expect it to start to come down anytime
between the end of the year and mid-2023
but it will keep adding to inflation
even as the housing market settles down
[Music]